- Well, good afternoon, everybody
and thank you for attending.
My name is Paul Murawski
and I head up Marketing
and Trademark Licensing
here at Yale University.
I'd like to first thank
the IT folks for asking me
to speak a little bit about my department
and you're probably all
wondering, why am I gonna speak,
what does marketing or
licensing have to do,
but actually, because
we manage the Yale marks
on a university basis,
we touch all departments
in one way, shape or form
over the course of a year.
But before I start, just
to give you a little bit
about my background, I
have been fortunate enough
to work at Yale for about three years.
I have been in the marketing
and licensing business my
entire life, about 40 years.
I come primarily out of
department store world,
with 17 years in department stores
and I've had my own consulting business,
and prior, also headed
Licensing and Retail
for the American Museum of
Natural History in New York City.
At Yale, I've, like I
said, been here three years
and I also sit on the Yale Committee
for Cooperative Research.
What I'd like to do is take
you through a little bit
about what we do and,
basically, it comes down
to three issues that
my department handles.
First is we take care of
protection of the Yale marks,
secondly, we try to establish
a marketing platform
for the Yale brand globally,
and third, we manage the licensing
so that we actually bring
in additional revenue
to the University through
the licensing contracts
that we provide.
And just to start with,
I thought I'd give you
a little overview of some of the things
that we do regarding
protection of brands, things
that we look at in order to make sure
the Yale brand is managed appropriately,
and the people that we find
we have the most concerns
with are, a lot of times,
outside contractors will
wanna use the Yale name
because they've done construction on Yale,
or they've produced a book
for Yale, or whatever.
So, what they like to do is they like
to take the Yale name,
put it on their website.
Well actually, you can't do that.
That's actually illegal.
It's actually a misuse of trademark.
So, we run into a lot of those issues.
We run into issues
with the power companies
misusing our names.
We've run into that, especially, overseas.
Recently, in Taiwan and in mainland China.
There's also been a case
where a company was
using Yale Kindergarten,
which, obviously, they can't do.
So, there's a lot of
different things that we try
to get in front of so that
the problems don't occur
and that we can actually
make it so it's easy
for the people who can use the Yale marks
to do it appropriately.
So first, what we've
done is we put some pegs
in the ground, some guidelines
for how to use the Yale brands, starting
with outside consultants and contractors,
and the most important thing there is
that, basically, it's not allowed.
You can't promote, sponsor, approve
of outside consultants or contractors,
or any goods or services, regardless
of the relationship with Yale.
So, it doesn't matter who the
company is, how big they are,
they can't use the Yale brand
because Yale is a
not-for-profit institution
and it cannot seem as
endorsing a corporate venture
related to commerce.
So secondly, the other area we
target is, are the students.
We love our students and
they're very creative
in the way they wanna use the Yale marks,
and it's very interesting
to see some of the things
they come to us with.
But, so what we wanted to do is we wanted
to create, put pegs in the
ground for the students
so they clearly understood
how to use the Yale mark,
but also not to crimp their
creativity, shall we say,
because you should see some of the things
that come across our
desk when it comes time
for the Harvard football
games or some of the events
that the students run in the dorms.
So, we have to be cautious of that.
So, what we've done is we
put together a guideline
for the students.
It was spurred on by the
Secretary of the University,
who has the actual rights to
use the marks as she see fits,
or her authorized agents,
which happens to be our department.
So, any student group that wants
to use the Yale name has to first register
with a student organization,
whether it's undergrad or grad,
to make sure they are a legitimate
entity of the University.
And also, they have to
make sure they comply
with the University's standards
regarding the guidelines
associated to use of the marks.
And we've established these,
along with the Office of General Counsel,
and they include things like your logo
and name must identify you
as a student organization.
You have to convey that in any way
that you present your organization.
That includes on your
emails, on your website,
on any paraphernalia or
swag that you wanna buy.
So, you have to convey
that student affiliation,
which you see some examples here.
Secondly, a lot of students say,
"Well, I can convey my affiliation by Yale
by saying 'at Yale,'"
but actually, you can't.
"At Yale" is tied to The
Shops at Yale downtown,
so you can't use "at Yale."
That does not allow you to comply
with the idea of being
a student organization
in relationship to the University.
Use of logos, this is
always very interesting
because this is where
the students get creative
and, certainly, we encourage that,
but things like you have to indicate
that you're a student organization,
like the Yale Undergraduate
Chamber Orchestra.
The two groups of marks
that are labeled able to use
are the Yale Block and the Yale "Y,"
but when using those two
logos, you cannot alter them.
So, in other words,
when we get, let's say,
swag for an event that one of
the colleges are going to use,
they can present it to
us, they can say Yale,
but they can't alter those two marks.
Also acronyms, if you use
an acronym, you also have
to indicate that you're
a student organization,
as you see here.
And items to be distributed,
this is my favorite.
So, if you use the word Yale
in your name and logo,
you also have to include
that you're a registered
student organization.
So, you see here the Yale Refugee Project.
Underneath it, it says an
undergraduate organization,
which is very important to note,
because what you have to
think about is a student
from one of the colleges
puts together a t-shirt
that has something that is,
could be considered offensive.
That student goes to New York City
on a Friday night, goes to
Grand Central Station, is seen
by thousands of people.
That's the image that
Yale's now portraying
to the world out there.
So, we have to be very cautious,
and when we look at something
in my department, it's
how does the world see it?
How is John Q. Public gonna
see Yale in that context?
And that's how we judge whether
it's appropriate or not.
And, of course, the one thing we also keep
in mind is you can't use
orange and you can't use red
because you don't wanna
be Princeton or Harvard.
(people in audience laugh)
But anyway,
so websites, that's another favorite.
Actually, we run into
this issue more than any
because it's really not that
students wanna do it wrong,
they just don't understand the guidelines
associated with that.
So, something like making
sure you have your logo
conspicuously on the website.
And, importantly, you
have to have a disclaimer,
because every student organization
is also insured by Yale,
so having that disclaimer is important
to let it know that it's
a student organization,
not a Yale University organization.
And also, the email addresses associated
to that have to be Yale email addresses.
You can't do gmail@Yale.com.
That's not allowed if you're
a student organization.
You have to tie to whatever email address
that the student in
charge of the group has.
So now you think about, okay,
now you can do the brand protection,
very important part of it.
This is an idea, last year
in fiscal 2018, we actually
dealt with 144 cases, globally,
of misuse of the Yale marks.
That's across the world.
Majority here in the United States,
but also we ran into in
Asia, we ran into in Europe,
ran into it in the Middle East.
So, those types of things
all come across our desk.
So, the idea is, say, okay,
what does Yale Licensing have
to do with that?
But, if you think about it
for a minute, if we're able
to market the Yale brand properly,
and we get it out there in
as many venues as possible,
people are gonna see, it's
gonna become more popular,
it's gonna become more important,
and people are gonna say,
"Well, gee, Yale, I see
Yale out there a lot.
"Do we really wanna do something
"that's gonna infringe on that?"
So, the licenses not only bring in royalty
to the University, but
also prevents the license
from being abused.
And, as an example of that,
like I say, we had 144 misuses last year.
This year, we've only had 72.
So, it is improving, it's
never gonna be perfect.
It's almost like Whac-A-Mole
sometimes, the number
of issues we get.
So, it's important that we continue
to market the brand,
license it appropriately,
and that is actually a
protection, an umbrella
for the Yale brand.
So licensing, what exactly is licensing?
There's a lot of questions
to it of how does it work,
what's the purpose of it,
and how is it managed?
Licensing at Yale is
Yale allows a company,
let's say Champion
Sportswear, to use its name
to market the Champion
and Yale brand together
and pays a royalty to the University.
That royalty goes back to the University,
into the student scholarship funds.
So, not only do we do a service
by marketing it through
a particular brand,
but we also do a service
by bringing cash back
into the University.
We're actually one of the few
totally self-sufficient
departments in the entire college.
We don't take any money from Yale.
Everything we make, salaries,
benefits, et cetera, all come
from licensing revenue.
We are employees of Yale, of
course, but we take our money
from the actual deals that we are able
to pull together within licensing.
So, one of the things we do,
and we're actually trying to
be a little bit more aggressive
in that, is how do you get the
Yale name out there globally?
I mean, you look out there,
the most popular collegiate
brand in the world is UCLA.
You would not believe that, but it is.
UCLA actually has 31 UCLA
stores in China itself.
The issue is people, and
same thing in Europe,
people don't understand
that UCLA is a university.
They just think it's a logo.
So, you think about that, how
much money they're making just
because they think their brand is a logo.
Couple that with the power
of our brand, the power
of the education behind Yale,
and it makes us a powerful entity
that we want to get out
there and tell people about.
Not the way UCLA does, but to truly speak
to the essence of Yale.
So, how do you do that?
We've done this a couple of ways.
We now, as a university,
aggressively attend all licensing
or major licensing shows
throughout the world.
We just came back from the
Las Vegas Licensing Expo,
which is the largest in the world,
over 40,000 people attended,
we were the only university there.
Next month, I'm gonna
be traveling to Mumbai.
I'm gonna be doing the
licensing show in Mumbai.
Our booth is gonna be
right next to Oxford's.
End of next month, I'm gonna
be traveling to Shanghai
to do the Shanghai licensing show.
We'll be right next to Cambridge.
And, in October, we'll be
doing the Brand Licensing Expo
in Europe to secure
brands in that continent.
So, we take a very aggressive approach
to get the Yale brand out
there internationally,
and also do protection
of it and licensing of it
from a domestic perspective.
So, when we're pitching a license
for a particular company,
how do you do that?
How do you say to somebody,
"Hey, do you want the Yale brand?"
Or they say to you, "Can
I have the Yale brand?"
It's a very interesting dichotomy
because I would say 75% of
the time, people come to us
to ask for use.
"Can we use the Yale brand?"
Well, yes you can, but there's
parameters that go around it.
We have to understand
the quality of the brand.
We have to understand what
kind of company you have.
We have to understand
that a, social rights.
Every licensee at Yale University has
to be a member of the
Fair Labor Association
to ensure that they are
protecting the workers,
no matter where they are in the world.
And one thing that we're
actually very proud of,
last year, or was it, I
guess it was two years ago,
there was an issue with
one of our licensees,
and I'm proud to say it was
Yale, Cornell, Georgetown,
and the University of
Washington actually put pressure
on this very large brand
to change their ways
in Vietnam and it worked.
And that brand was Nike.
Nike does not want to hear
that Yale pulled away from them
because they're doing
something illegal overseas.
So, I'm proud of the fact that Yale has
that, I guess, check and balance
to make sure you don't
run into those problems,
and if we do, we have the help
of the Fair Labor Association
to deal with that.
So, when we're pitching to a brand,
or a brand's pitching to us,
I'm gonna give you an idea
of how we do that and how we speak to that
and how it then becomes a partnership
with us as the licensing partner.
Revenue of the University,
marketing of the Yale brand.
So, the first thing you
want to do is, you want
to tell them about the University.
What they love to hear
about is the history
and the panache of an
Ivy League institution.
Founded in 1701, renowned
What's the Yale mission?
And we explain the Yale mission,
but also how does licensing products speak
to that Yale mission?
It does because it helps to
serve and promote the brand
throughout the world.
And, of course, they want
to see what Yale looks like,
'cause if I'm in Mumbai or I'm in Shanghai
or Las Vegas, people
have an envision of Yale,
but what is it really like?
So, being able to show potential licensees
what it looks like, you
get the wow factor and say,
"Wow, I really want to be
associated with that university.
"I was right to come
to the licensing booth
"and try to get that brand."
So, Yale by the numbers,
and the next question you
always get when you're talking
to a potential licensee
is, "Well, how big is Yale?
"How many people go to Yale?
"What's the alumni?"
So that type of
information, very important.
And the thing that people always look at,
we have 144,000 living alumni, globally.
That's very important,
especially if you're speaking
to somebody overseas.
Athletics plays a huge role at Yale.
If you think about all the
licenses that we have here,
about 144 licenses globally,
the largest ones are related
to athletics, primarily
Champion, Under Armour,
and so forth.
We speak to the teams
that are related to that.
We speak to, of course,
the Harvard-Yale game,
which everyone wants to be a part of,
because when you got 60
or 70,000 people at Yale
for a weekend, how great
is that for a brand?
And, of course, who came to Yale?
Of course, the Bushes came to Yale,
the Clintons came to Yale, they love
to hear stories about that.
Handsome Dan.
You would think that,
okay, he's a Bulldog.
Well, the Bulldog's from 1889.
It's the oldest mascot
in the United States.
It was so important
that our Japanese agent
actually did a whole program
of Yale vintage products
based on Handsome Dan.
It was very, very successful,
and now we're spreading
that to other countries,
including Korea and mainland China.
What does the Yale brand mean?
What the Yale brand means
is a promise of excellence.
When you think of Yale,
what do you think about?
You think about excellent education.
Well, we want the product to
speak of excellence, also.
Only the finest quality,
only the best factories,
only the best names, in order to make sure
that we are presenting Yale in a manner
that it should be presented in.
The logos and word marks, most popular.
On the left, the University
logo institutional mark.
That is reserved for what we
call some better products.
It is the Yale University logo itself,
and you don't see that
as much as you see some
of the other ones.
The athletic mark is actually being played
down a little bit recently,
so it's not as popular as it was.
The most popular word
mark is the Yale block.
You are going to see that, probably,
on 75% of the items that are out there
that are licensed by Yale.
Other word marks, the "Y,"
Yale Bulldogs, Yale University.
But the interesting thing is,
when you think Yale University,
that would be a big play?
It really is only a big play in Asia.
It's actually, only the
Japanese market actually uses
that for product right now,
as well as the United States.
Vintage logos.
This is becoming a real trend
in the market right now.
You go to any college store
that carries collegiate
products right now,
that whole vintage look,
the look that went back
to the 50s and 60s, becoming
very important again.
So, you'll see that the leaning Bulldog,
the golf course logo, the
script Yale University,
which we just used for a
program in the United States,
and Established 1701.
Now, licensing at Yale.
What exactly do we offer or can we offer
to somebody who wants to
work with our institution?
Whoops, there we go.
We want them to share a
vision of product excellence.
Only the finest quality.
We take a global approach.
We just don't want to say,
"Hey, we'll take your license,
we'll take your money."
No, that's not the way it works.
The idea is that we want to work with you
to make it successful for the
licensee, make it successful
for the marketing of the Yale brand,
and make it successful for the revenue
that we're going to bring
into the institution.
And the idea of it is we are one
of the most prestigious
universities in the world,
and the amount of materials,
the array of materials
that you have that you can use
to actually enhance the Yale brand,
as per a licensing perspective, is huge.
Now, in the United States,
we have roughly 140 domestic
licensees, you see some
of the main ones there,
largest being Champion.
Under Armor, of course,
has our sideline deal,
so you see that when you
go to football games.
Nike used to have the sideline
deal, doesn't any longer,
but still a good, big player.
Vineyard Vines.
We're the only university
in the United States
to have a collegiate
license with Lululemon.
And also 47 Brand, who does
all, a lot of headwear,
especially for the Major League Baseball.
Now, some of the companies
that we do business with, you
think that, okay, yeah, Yale's
in the book store, Yale's
in Campus Customs, Yale's
with some other stores downtown.
Actually, that's not the truth.
Actually, Yale is all over the country
in stores that you wouldn't expect.
We were in Neiman Marcus this year, we're
in PacSun right now, we were
in Barneys, every year we're
in Forever 21.
Dick's Sporting Goods, Fanatics.
So, it's not just downtown Broadway,
it's actually a national program
here in the United States
with a lot of major retailers.
Now, around the world, we also revamped
our entire licensing
program around the world
in order to have as a global hand
in all major markets, includes
the Middle East, Europe,
and Russia, Hong Kong, mainland China,
Japan, Southeast Asia, and in Canada.
Actually, Canada's growing
nicely for us right now.
Now, who do we work with around the world?
You wouldn't expect these brands
to be associated with Yale,
but they are.
Champion Japan, we just
signed Champion Japan.
That was a major program
based on the success
of Champion United States,
and we're now working
and negotiating with Champion Taiwan.
Two years ago, we had a
global program with Zara.
Over 2,400 stores worldwide.
This year, we had a global
program with Calvin Klein.
Now, you wouldn't think
Calvin Klein and Yale,
but actually, we did.
Actually, we were a global
program with Calvin Klein,
and we actually presented at a runway
in Milan last July of Yale product,
along with the University of
California all pulled together,
which was very, very successful.
Now, how do you grow that,
you have to think about it,
and one of the questions you get,
"Well, how do you choose which
license you want to use?"
Well, you have to take
a more global approach.
Who's the best one you want to work with?
Okay, if you work with Calvin Klein,
so that creates an umbrella for the brand.
Zara, your fast fashion.
But you also don't want
to walk away from somebody
who is maybe at the opening
price point, like a Primark.
We do business, which is
a London-based company.
We also do business
with Winners in Canada.
We do business with Wal-Mart.
The thought is here is,
we have t-shirts in Wal-Mart right now,
and you say to yourself, "Is that Yale?
"Is that who Yale wants to present to?"
Well, actually, it is.
'Cause you think about it,
there's gonna be people
in this world who'll never see
the Yale University campus.
They'll only see it on
TV, they may never be able
to get to Yale.
But, by having a t-shirt
at the opening price
point makes them feel like
they're a part of one of
the most famous universities
in the world, and we're inspired by that
and we believe in that.
So, that's why we also
sell to your Wal-Marts
of the world, your Zaras of the world,
and we carry the brand of Calvin Klein.
And how we break down?
It jumped a little bit,
but that big, blue area
is actually apparel
as the largest part, as you would imagine.
And within that, again, this
slide jumped a little bit,
but men's apparel represents
about 2/3 of the apparel
that we do.
And this jumped a little bit, too.
In the non-apparel, the
largest area would be
in school products, such as
back-to-school backpacks,
paper goods, et cetera.
Recent licensing programs in Yale, just
to give you an idea of some of the things
that have happened recently
for us, to give you an idea
of where we're taking the brand.
The Yale Co-Op Shirt.
I don't know how many people
remember the old Co-Op Shirt
from Gant years and years ago.
It's been around since 1949.
Gant decided they didn't want to work
with us anymore back in 2014.
We've now relaunched that
through Vineyard Vines
and that's the ad that ran
in the alumni magazine this past month.
Lululemon, as I mentioned,
we're the only university
in the United States to
carry the Lululemon brand,
and vice versa.
Forever 21, we run a program every year
with Forever 21, extremely popular.
This is the one that we ran this fall.
And Calvin Klein.
This product ranged anywhere
from a few dollars up
to over $2,000 for the product,
depending what you purchased.
That cashmere, that coat
all the way on the left
that the young man's wearing,
that's a $25 cashmere coat.
They produced only six of them worldwide
and sold them primarily in Europe.
And, of course, Zara,
this was the global brand
that we did with Zara two years ago.
And just some other examples
for you to see here.
These are some things that
are going on right now.
You see your traditional
Yale look on the left.
You see the leaning
Bulldog, part of PacSun,
and the other two, that's
actually JCPenney's website.
We're not carrying the
store, but we're actually
on JCPenney's website, which
speaks very highly of us.
And here's some examples
of the women's brand.
So yes, we have t-shirts
that you would expect
and we carry a plethora of
those, but also other looks
that are exciting, that
are fashion-forward
so that Yale is not only your
t-shirts and sweatshirts,
but something a little bit higher.
And some of the non-apparel things,
and these are some fun items that we carry
that we actually make here
and we actually manage this process
for these items here, right in our office.
This is called the Yale collection,
and these are items that
are only available online.
You see the stadium there,
you see Handsome Dan,
that's our best seller, a
replica football from the 1920s.
Again, licensing products
that you wouldn't expect.
The Yale bowl.
This is a hand-cut, ceramic bowl.
Every piece is slightly different.
That retails for $600,
we've already sold four
of them downtown in the dwell store.
And, of course, accessories.
Very popular tote on the
left actually includes a map
of the town of New Haven inside it.
The little bracelet,
that's actually a mini-map
of Yale in there.
So, we try things that
are different, unusual.
Things you're not gonna expect out there.
So, what does the Yale
licensing program offer?
It's an evergreen brand,
always gonna be there.
We've been here for 300 years,
we're gonna be here for 300 more.
A wide range of intellectual properties.
You see all the number of
marks that were offered.
Local representation so
that we can actually work
with the brand to make it successful.
And an engaged management team,
which we like to think
we are in our office.
So, that gives you an idea of what we do
with the Licensing Department,
how it intertwines.
So not only do we manage
the licensing royalties
that come in, we manage the
brands, we manage the property
of Yale to make sure that
it's actually as pristine
as it should be.
Thank you.
(crowd applauds)
(light vibraphone music)